The Joe Rogan experience and they
create all these amazing fighters.
There's so many great fighters and Russell
and wrestlers that have come out of
Russia.
Former Soviet Union.
I can drag off rocky f
five or four. Four. Yeah.
The new one was scary to knew what
he was afraid of. New Creed. Rocky's.
Yeah. You know that I've heard. I haven't
seen it yet. Yeah. Drago son is fighting.
Who is this guy? Creed's son till we know
the actor. Is it out yet? The creed guy?
No, I think this is the
son of a Drago. I Dunno.
Some Russian cat. Okay.
[inaudible] already famous over
here. I'd like to think so.
I don't think so. Yeah. There's the
guy. Look at him. There's drill. Go.
Yeah. This is his son diseases.
My sauce. Like a bad ass. He does.
He's still a bad ass. I'm sure that,
that his jaw was perfectly square.
That's like a dam square come much bigger.
You know,
like rocky writes.
How tall is a Sylvester?
I don't know. I think you
met him. Yes. Well, yes. Um,
I think he's got about five. Nine.
He's taller than me. I'm five.
Eight okay. So he's either
five, nine or five. 10 okay.
So that the drug up must be huge.
Like how it tells you to say he is,
cause everybody was jokes around and
says he's five 11 or a that these five,
seven, five, five. But they do that
with everybody. Yeah. They do that.
Tom Cruise,
it's his five 10 see that makes sense.
So He's two inches taller than me.
Five 10 yeah. Okay. Well, yeah,
I think I'm five nine. I don't know. I
haven't measured myself in a while. Hello?
How, how tall do you think I am? I think
you're about that. About five. Nine. Yeah.
In high school, I always put
like five, 10, five, 11 bigger.
Now we're old people that are small
and as people get bigger and bigger,
these kids today that are getting hitting
puberty when they're six yeah. Luke,
there's hormones in the meat [inaudible]
six five [inaudible] who's [inaudible]?
They'd probably accentuated his
height for that. That scene,
that's just his hair is five
inches. Look at that down. The hair.
Looks like he's almost like a foot
taller than them, doesn't it? Yeah. Yeah,
they probably had, that's about,
they probably had him in heels.
And how the sessional on barefoot
or something for that shot.
Didn't they say like, uh, at one point
during this movie, Rocky said, uh,
go ahead and uh, go ahead. Hit me for
real one time. Just what, you know,
make it look real. Cause they
were always like, you know,
they're like an anthropology and the
swings and it almost hit him to the
hospital. Like he hit him in the chest
ride. Yeah, he talked about that.
Almost stopped his heart shit down.
My idea doll from drones. Right?
He's a senior professional. Yeah.
He's a kickbox kickboxing. Yeah.
Really Good Sylvester Stallone Lundgren
put me in the hospital during rocky four.
Yeah, I believe it. The
only people hit you bro.
He also had to realism bell, I guess. I
wonder if they even use the clip. Right.
Um,
he um,
also has like screws in his
neck from doing the expendables.
Oh yeah. Yeah. What do you got chain?
He's put in intensive care
for five days because of that.
With nuns walking around.
Jesus Christ.
Wow. Insurance Company would not pay out
until after they saw the footage of the
incident. Once they did, they wrote
the check. I want to see that footage.
He said he didn't see that punch.
He hit my heart so hard that it banged
against my ribs and started to swell.
And that usually happens in
car accidents. Oh my God. Well,
Jesus, that guy can punch. He's
a beast, man. He's a giant dude.
Why would he ever needs a serious striker?
Like he knows how to throw shots.
If you watch him in his movies, he's
uh, he's obviously trained. Yeah.
I want to say that footage. I want to say
that Po ouch. That's gotta be out there.
But if it's Sylvester Stallone
wouldn't let anybody see it.
The way isn't wants to embarrass
him the way. Wait, cried.
So we were faced.
He's like that lady who steps on grapes,
who falls down.
Oh Wow.
She loses her breath.
You can never be an action hero again.
If somebody sees you
cry. That's true. Right?
If someone sees he like legitimately
cry from the liver shot. Whoa.
You just shit yourself. And
he's looking at the camera. Why.